jumping into
uh guardians just real fast uh where are
you in the in the writing process like
do you have a
finished draft that you're super happy
with
yeah yeah it's basically been finished
for years i keep fiddling with different
things and adding things and
figuring out permutations and stuff i'm
in the middle of doing
another draft now but it's it's it's
really small
stuff in comparison to what it has been
it's basically been finished before
you know three years ago where and when
are you filming filming in
georgia and starting in november
got it uh i think fans are curious when
you're when you were writing that script
did you have any sort of and i don't
know how it works with marvel
but do they say to you we really need
you to hit these things
or we need to include this or is it
pretty much like
just give us the script and let's you
know what i mean like what is that
dynamic like
never the only time they ever did that
was on the first movie
uh with thanos and putting thanos in
there
uh which they wanted me to do but
besides that they've never done that
volume you know you know i have to pay
attention to things that happened which
they did talk to me about you know the
stuff with gamora and things like that
um you know i know that the characters
have been through certain things
um so i have to deal with that stuff um
but for the most part
uh yeah they've never once asked me to
put
anything into the script for volume 3 to
set up anything in the future
nor would i do it frankly it's not
really my thing you know
is it going to be called guardians of
the galaxy volume 3 yeah